our brandy exclusive she has hot new
music that just dropped and she is
speaking out for the first time about
the passing of longtime friend Kobe
Bryant it just stopped me dead in my
tracks I just could not understand it I
don't understand it I'll never
understand it to this day
Brandi and Kobe shared a special
friendship his first Hollywood acting
gig was on her sitcom Moishe how's he
doing he's doing great
well first time active I pay the
decision I don't even it's unbelievable
I can't believe it and honestly I would
have to say that shook my faith that
moment really shook my faith we've heard
reports that you guys are dating or
you're we went to the prom together did
you hear that
probably hear that yeah he'll always be
my date randy was just 17 when we were
on set that's the same age her daughter
Surratt is now how is corn team life
going when you have someone who is 17
you know what it's really tough because
you know she's so active and she
definitely wants to get out the house
and you know the mall is not open you
know and we don't see eye to eye all the
time we're just happy that we have each
other
while we're all sitting in our rooms
Brandy's dropping a new song in honor of
her daughter's 18th birthday next month
and Mother's Day and I wanted to do a
song about my love and my unconditional
love with my daughter
our bond is beginning of the new project
absolutely yes I mean it's been so long
Brandy's last album was nearly 8 years
ago and she's not the only one in her
house with the new track
Sarah just recorded and released her
first song I heard it and I was
completely blown away I mean I've shed
so many tears just hearing her voice
maybe it out bird oh it will definitely
be an album for her I'm still protective
in this business is crazy
[Music]